c'est maintenant j'accueille gas toits
rouges pour est belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
robin bientôt juillet rien ou thierry
vous partez skier ou
non je dis ça il faut réserver
maintenant est-ce que moi aussi je fais
partie des aoûtiens
j'aime pas y aller en juillet parce que
tu es sûr de voir mettre les chaînes
quoi ça
moi j'adore parler de la météo quand la
météo c'est quand même la mondanité à la
portée des ploucs quoi sceller change
ryanair s'est quant à un lien social
minimal tu parles de la prostate du
voisin quand a aucun lien tu parles de
la prostate de dieu c'est
mariage premier mariage gay a été
célébrée mercredi bon pourquoi pas tout
cas moi je serai guèye ce qui arrive ce
qui risque pas d'arriver je déteste
coldplay mais
moi je réglais au mariage je demanderais
d'être considérés comme les pouces bah
ouais comme ça en cas de divorce était
sûr d'avoir la garde des enfants
à risque avec deux paires qui sépare ce
sera forcément une garde partagée
résultat les gamins vont être en
permanence tiraillé entre deux foyers
donc le mariage homosexuel créé des
enfants instable cqfd [ __ ] j'suis
brillant mais alors
alcool car rapport un mec qui a dépensé
42 mille euros en boîte en champagne
avec la carte de crédit de son père il
serait temps qu'ils se calment le fils
fabius quoi
mais non c'était pas fabius mais non
alors
ça s'est passé au japon ça devait être
le fils de jean vincent placé
alors vous allez me dire ouais non mais
ils les coréens coréen moncayo est
comme si ça changeait quelque chose
radicalité mahomet ten alors l'agresseur
de militaires à la défense a été
retrouvé grâce à son passe navigo
forcément un terroriste qui frotte pas
la ratp les gens sont surpris quoi
mais bon c'est juste que techniquement
essaye de sauter au dessus d'un
tourniquet avec une djellaba
nouveauté le type s'appelle alexandre ce
n'était pas évident alors il a cru que
ça suffisait pour pas se faire remarquer
ce que son complice a lui dire non mais
tu vas pas y aller comme ça tu vas te
faire repérer que tu avances à mai est
inquiète pas j'ai un nom français je
vais percevoir 2 parce qu'en terme de
camouflage il n'a pas mis le paquet
barbe djellaba calotte c'est le le
bling-bling fondamentalistes
le halal décomplexée d'ailleurs le gars
tu dois arriver de loin tu comprends que
c'est pas un village people que c'est un
rude alors tout de suite des réactions
outrées c'est l'imam de drancy
si vous trouvez que l'islam en france ne
vous convient pas allez vous-en quitté
la france à ces animaux c'est un animal
qui a dit ça quand une bande façon un
imam c'est forcément très moderne rien
que le nom imams on dirait un produit
apple
c'est mais c'est bon c'est pas
raisonnable de dire des trucs pareils
quoi renvoyer tous les intégristes chez
eux fâché je rappelle qu'on a qu'un seul
porte avions
puis la france tu les aimes ou tu la
quittes c'est quand même un slogan à la
con quand je viens comme si les couples
rester ensemble parce qu'il sait mais
pour un islamiste la france c'est comme
un plan que la nana elle a beau avoir
des mycoses elle au moins elle accueille
toute la misère du monde
c'est une idée dans la foulée elle a
arrêté aussi redoine faïd en ce moment
où valsent il a un truc avec l'afrique
du nord quoi à ce rythme là dans un mois
il retrouve ce modèle
redoine faïd a été arrêté dans un hôtel
de pontault combault c'est vraiment la
déchéance et c'est comme rambo qui sont
enfuis d'une prison vietnamienne et qui
se fait coffrer parce qu'il s'était garé
à une place réservée aux handicapés
bref décès il nous a quittés ce grand
musicien qui a profondément marqué la
vie des français par son sens de la
ritournelle je veux parler de jeff
hanneman le guitariste de slayer alors
slayer c'est un groupe extraordinaire
c'est vraiment pas de la musique de fin
pour tous quoi
non mais slayer quand t'écoutes clair on
dirait jennifer mais en train de se
faire violer
non
fait divers
un homme qui se suicide dans une
maternelle je comprend déjà un gosse qui
cherche dans un tgv c'est dur mais alors
une classe
[Applaudissements]
évidemment on l'a fait tout un cirque à
le débrief psychologique des pauvre
petit chou c'est bon les gamins ils sont
dans une école du 7e on les traite comme
si on revenait d'une mission à kaboul
quand on met mon gosse si on rentre à la
maison il ya cinq ans il me dirait pape
à l école est un monsieur qui se tire
une balle dans la tête moi je lui
réponds j'espère que tu as aider à
débarrasser
j'espère que tu as débarrasser au lieu
de rester planté là comme un conte
attendent que marcel rufo viens de te
dire que si tu nous emmerdes avec des
cauchemars pendant trois mois c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas su accueillir ta
petite souffrance de [ __ ] occidentale
sur gâtés dont l'imagination anorexique
et incapable d'envisager 30 secondes que
le type avait juste du coulis de tomates
dans le crâne combat
alors éducation le gouvernement va sévir
contre les tricheurs au bac 1 ah bon vu
le niveau est encore besoin de tricher
presse il paraît que libé à moins de
cent mille lecteurs selon la police où
selon libé
non parce que 100000 ça me semble
beaucoup quand je
démarre en force de taper
pardon tuning
elle voulait se faire refaire les fesses
et se fait amputer les bras et des
jambes
de quoi s plein bien s'embrassant pied
s'il ya bien une chose qu'on va plus
regarder ces sons cure
[Applaudissements]
football important parler un peu de
sport et à créteil fait une croix sur
bague à l'isle d'abeau
et à toutes une interview dans les pages
ligue des champions ile-de-france alors
baghadi davos est un type super
prometteur quand il il rêve de jouer en
ligue 1 il ya encore des mecs comme ça
quand on oublie trop souvent et dans ce
pays il ya des footballeurs qui rêve
juste de jouer à montpellier ou à brest
alors bon bien sûr bon c'est ça ça reste
du foot de seconde division quoi c'est
passionnant mais ça n'arrivera jamais à
la cheville du hand ball féminin quoi c
gepa si vous avez suivi le match entre
fleury loiret ms
le but de pauline beaudoin
c'est avec la main la balle dans le
filet la balle elle tombe tipi la
ramasse comme fallait voir la salle soit
quinze personnes en délire
si j'étais né au wahoo qua non lille
beaudoin [ __ ] et c'est une fille
célibataire
cinéma il ya une campagne actuellement
d'acteurs contre la surpêche alors pour
attirer l'attention fait poser des stars
à poil à côté de poissons et mollusques
ça c'est le grand truc contemporain pour
attirer l'attention faut se foutra près
d'eilat tu vois mélanie laurent avec un
tourteau pour dire il faut arrêter de
vider les réserves de la mer
ah bon et elle est le fait quoi là le
crabe après la science et crois qu'on va
le ramener en taxi à l'île de ré plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je me disais un truc en fait les
animaux ils sont tout le temps tout nu
oui la nature c'est d'une indécence
alors pas belle la vie elle très bonne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux